so well I'm fooled today we've got a
present at one of our viewers as centers
present this mysterious box and check
out check out the warning on the box
warning contains numbers exciting I
think so
so shall we open up the box and see what
this present is we actually got two of
these one for Brady one for me we really
appreciate that thank you very much for
sending this there we go we have got
some mysterious object here not sure
what it is yet Brady what do you think
yeah what do you think it's going to be
we're gonna have to plug it in now I
think you should yours Brady I think you
should have the first press of the big
red button I have no idea what's going
to happen here oh joy try it again now
have you worked out what it's doing yet
these are prime numbers each one is a
new prime number it's a prime number
generator this was made by our viewer
Cole Altman and he makes kinetic
sculptures so these are sculptures that
move and do exciting things and he's
made well a short series of these and he
sent us a couple and you'll get the next
prime number are and he's so satisfying
especially if you like having a big red
button to press and it gives you a
feeling of the gaps between the primes
as well you see how you have some are
short oh that was nice that was
satisfying a nice long gap it's really
nice I I mean it's a bit of silly fun
there's no practical use to it or
anything but I love it
can't reset it you're stuck now you have
to go through all the primes until you
reach 999,999 and it will wrap back to
zero now we're about 250 1000 here now
the prime number theorem one of the big
theorems and mathematics says that the
average gap between the primes should be
round about the natural log of 251,000 I
know that's about 12 so the average gap
should be about 12 so we're going to be
bigger than 12 so a small sometimes you
get a twin prime sometimes you get a
long gap but the really exciting number
to wait for is 490 2113 because at 490
2113 you get the longest prime gap that
this machine can generate it's a gap of
114 so I think that will be an exciting
day when we can get to 490 2113 so Carl
has put in a microprocessor in this I
don't think it's doing anything clever I
think it counts the gaps between the
primes and he only has a few of these
and perhaps we can put a link to his
website and he can tell people about his
work that would be nice and but when
they're gone they're gone I'm afraid it
was such a surprise I got a huge box at
my delivered to my work and I had no
idea what it was I wasn't told it was
coming so this huge box and digging
through all this packaging and then this
is what comes out the other side and I
mean I plugged it in it was giving me to
me with a letter so I did kind of know
what it was and but it's there it's the
ice the clicking noise I mean I was so
full you do realize I had to pay the
import tax for this yeah he paid me back
he paid me back do you know what I
really want a twin Prime
give us a twin prime of course of course
I'll do that for you it could be this
about a sexy Prime was that time I think
that might have been a twin prime then
whoo twin fro and it shows you it shows
you does actually show you something
about the randomness of the primes they
turn up frequently but they're kind of
unpredictable as well
Karla's very kindly signed it for us
he's dated it on his numbered the the
primer that's what he's called it its
primer number four and I just showed
this to Brady we hear he was very
disappointed cuz he hasn't got a prime
number
I got prime I got number three like a
primer number three